meantime businesses though still have
the option to require masks some salons
and spas are still asking for mass to be
worn by their customers joe mohler is
live near buffalo and sahara with the
changes that some salons are making joe
denise don't get rid of that mass just
yet we stopped in several salons and
spas and some of them are still going to
be requiring mass moving forward but
others like
this one right here layla social salon
they say it's up to the customer and the
stylist
it's really nice to see the way a
haircut or style
lays on the face spas and salons are
okay with the change throughout the
pandemic stylist and nail technicians
have been up close and personal with
clients a mask had been required up
until now they're absolutely welcome to
wear masks stylist olivia richards from
layla salon says they are leaving it up
to customers and stylists if they decide
that they want their stylist to wear a
mask they're absolutely welcome to
request it and we are happy to
accommodate most spas and nail salons we
stopped in were following the same rules
but not all of them maracai salon in the
northwest valley still wants people to
mask up our clients are happy our
stylists are happy we all feel safe the
owner bernicia carrera explained why we
have a lot of immune compromised clients
we have clients that families you know
have passed away we have six clients
actually that passed away from
the virus so we chose to continue to
wear it and we asked and we're getting
great feedback guerra says if a client
does not want to wear it they will make
a special time for them to come in to
stay healthy this is what we choose
stylist selena nakawoka says she feels
safer keeping the mask we're working so
close to our clients
we're in our face we do hair we do
makeup we do microblading we do
eyelashes
i just think it
makes us feel much more comfortable as
well as our clients that we care
the best thing to do if you do have an
appointment at a spa or salon is to call
ahead see what their mass policy is or
even just bring a mask with you
reporting live at buffalo and sahara
this evening jim muller live local now